it is the great brexit trade-off on
trade that is still not settled remain
within a new customs union within Europe
to protect existing trade flows in
manufacturing or cut free and sign new
deals elsewhere 18 months on from the
referendum the government gets to make
up its mind says we will leave this
trading arrangement that ensures the
free flow of parts and goods without
checks helping for example the car
industry but that free flow requiring a
common external tariff around all the EU
countries and that limits the ability to
do new trade deals abroad for that
reason the government ruled out staying
in the customs union but now it's making
preparations to allow it to rejoin
immediately a customs union covering the
same area as Turkey has done for the
past two decades
indeed the message in ports around the
country used to the free flow of
European trade such as Portsmouth is
that they need clarity on huge changes
that could hit within months about 40%
of the UK's trade is on road and
roll-off
and it's usually this just-in-time
supply chain could be fresh produce
could be car parts and so any delays
could have a disastrous economic effect
moderate foreign secretary the phase one
agreement particularly on the Irish
border puts the customs union back on
the agenda and it's talk of a new one
that's caused big new splits in cabinets
with a proxy war being fought between
the CBI
with other business organizations and
Tory Euroskeptic groupings the CBI which
seems to be the provisional wing of the
Treasury is pushing for it and this is a
great mistake that the customs you mean
higher prices of food clothing and
footwear
is very difficult if we leave the
customs union and join a customs union
it'll have to be very similar to the
customs union so it's just a semantic
game then the fear must be that this is
to get us back into the customs union by
the backdoor the government repeatedly
tells everybody that the United Kingdom
is going to leave the customs union of
the European Union and yet at the very
same time it is legislating with this
bill to allow fast-track powers to form
a new customs union with the European
Union and not just that it specifically
allows government ministers to apply a
common external tariff to and yet the PM
specifically said no to this at
Lancaster House I do not want Britain to
be part of the common commercial policy
and I do not want us to be bound by the
common external tariff in the Lancaster
House speech the prime minister said I
do not want us to be bound by the common
external tariff it seems to be rowing
back from the Lancaster House speech I
was confused as you are as to why that
anyone in the Treasury would want to
undermine the Prime Minister if Treasury
civil servants are undermining the Prime
Minister that is a constitutional issue
of considerable importance but for the
business groups it is a simple equation
that right now button friction in the
bulk of trade with the continent is not
outweighed by the current prospects for
quick new trade deals elsewhere
meanwhile businesses clamoring for
details of how the custom systems will
work were the checks for the origin of
manufacturing parts will occur
last year breads it forensics reported
that car companies were disillusioned
with a lack of detail in plans in areas
where basic preparation is required such
as the port infrastructure around Dover
concern remains it's not just a
motorways that we need solutions for we
need lorry parks not just in the m20 but
in other parts of the country we need to
make sure that the traffic can flow not
just on the motorways but in the towns
and villages of Kent as well
but you can't put in planning approvals
for lorry parks or anything without a
firm cabinet position for new customs
arrangements
that incredibly still being debated in
private the argument not yet settled and
really rather fits faster Islam Sky News
[Music]